what i like is that you're able to stop
by here it's not too hard because you
live in vegas you're not that far away i
was in town doing another job
for a game show which is one of my loves
and i live in vegas which is do you like
it there well i like no traffic compared
to here i mean yeah that part would be i
left at one this morning to get down
here yeah
so uh
but the traffic but you know vegas a
young person's town
because you know i don't even go to the
strip the last time i went to the strip
there were 5 000 people in a nightclub
yeah you know and when you're young you
can drink
and you should fall over but
you're
you know when young people drink they
can get so drunk
that they their eat their like
inner gyroscope takes over
[Laughter]
and it keeps them up yeah yeah and then
they focus on you hey
then you know they're drunk when they're
making wrestling sounds
i've never been that drunk you know yeah
i've been that full
[Laughter]
really you make those thoughts when
you're full ah
you know after a big meal
[Laughter]
you have to have a giant meal which is a
very american tradition and the waiter
waitress comes out and goes ebay save
room for dessert
and i go oh
i always like to say i'll have one
dessert or six desserts and one spoon
yeah
yeah i screwed that joke yeah that's all
right
this is how that joke goes
i'll have six desserts and one spoon
we could you know fix that with editing
it would be seamless but
we're not gonna spend the time on that
uh we like to see this yeah yeah yeah
yeah like you said i'm real man
man we're gonna see you do it twice
you